elle étale la maison folie de wazemmes
ces données missions associées au
maximum les habitants du quartier à
l'aide de la structure alors même si la
maison fonctionne depuis déjà 7 à moi
c'est aujourd'hui lors de l'inauguration
officielle qu'il s'attend vraiment le
lieu c'est quand même un quartier qui
est assez populaire où les gens sont
assez dynamiques et où il essaie quand
même de construire leur vie de quartier
donc oui moi je pense que ça va ça va
fonctionner va falloir s'investir en
fait mais bon j'espère que ça pourra
bien fonctionné mais je sais pas encore
comment nous en tant qu'habitant on
pourra participer
l'objectif est de permettre aux
habitants de travailler directement avec
les artistes seront d'ailleurs accueilli
en résidence certaines conditions et
puis aussi ouvrir au quartier des tiers
pistes telles que le hammam la salle de
convivialité avec cuisine ou encore des
ateliers
dites moi ce n'est pas un prototype
aujourd'hui on a encore un problème de
compréhension de ce projet aussi bien
envers la population proche que même des
compagnies d'artistes en utilisant ce
lieu moi je vois là c'est flagrant
depuis trois semaines ya vraiment des
choses qui se passent aujourd'hui on a
un espace qui va nous permettre de
pouvoir organiser des pique niques le
dimanche on a une brasserie qui va se
mettre en route petit à petit donc ça
devient vraiment un lieu de vie et et
tout ça va s'articuler j'en suis j'en
suis persuadé et c'est vrai que les
habitants commencent à connaître
l'endroit recèle la foule